50 grand 50 000
are these the most expensive headphones
on the planet that's truly unbelievable
50 000
for a pair of headphones how can i not
want these
i look at the price again and i scoff
but then i remember that none of this
is real or my money
it's time to look into shoes nike 711
dunk low
sb 1 555 i love it like on my screen
i love the theory of the shoe i mean i
don't know why i like a branded shoe
with like a non-shoe brand even though
it is nike all over it but i love nike
but 7-eleven i mean it's like
having coca-cola on your shoe i will say
this i don't love
just like red just plain red
don't love it as a color end of the day
i'm not paying fifteen hundred dollars
for a shoe
no new shoe stussy dunk glow pro sb
cherry 3050 unlike the last shoe i
love this color combination brown is one
of my favorite colors
this is a great shoe you know i look at
the price again
and i scoff i think no way but then
i remember that none of this is real or
my money
i love this shoe going to be a tough
shoe to beat can't even imagine a shoe
bead it looks like my dream shoe
ugh not my biggest uh fan
of the shoe nike dunk high pro sb
reverse
skunk 5600 hate high tops
not gonna ever sell me on a high top i
think they look dumb
nike undefeated zoom kobe 5 pro
tro hall of fame i am the biggest kobe
bryant fan
love him one of my biggest influences of
my whole life
not sure i would be the same guy if kobe
didn't exist i was at kobe's last game
when he scored 60 points
i figure if i get these kobe's start jab
step and start hitting a few pump fakes
i need to get back on the quarters in a
whole year of inactivity my body is
creaking what once was
springy and fast twitch is now
sloth-like all of that being said this
is the new leader no question i can't
even believe it took me that long to
realize that
i'm on to the adidas yeezy boost 700
mnvn
honey flux okay here's my thought about
this shoe kanye
i really love it yellow is just not my
favorite color as a man especially on me
but i love this shoe i love the design i
totally understand what you're doing or
at least it's impacting me i think the
way that you
want it to impact me kanye this isn't
anything to do with you it's more of my
love for kobe i know you're gonna
understand i'm also not
well i'm going to do columbia i don't
care what else i see
olivia lace-up leather and shirling
loafers
i mean these are really cool borderline
morally obligated to get these kobe's
but i want them and i need the kobe's
are more of the practical decision for
sure
like anything else would just be glitz
or glamour these kobe's
i need them like like just from a blue
collar perspective
and the users look cool they look like
they're fake they look like they're a
cartoon
in a good way i love non-reality
the kobe's though
[Music]
all right headphones i honestly i love
headphones there's not many things i
wear more
actively than like headphones matter so
much to me very excited to jump into the
headphones
bang and olufsen bo play h95 adaptive
anc
headphones cool like the way they look
they look high-end
850 that's cool they look so soft
and like they look like they'd always be
a little cool i feel like no matter what
you want your headphones to be
have a little cool audis
lcd 4z i mean price jumped up with this
one 3995 dollars for this sucker
that's a lot of money it's a lot of cash
it kind of looks like a basketball but
like
uh also like the logo of a planet
and i like space and sports there's a
little antenna coming out the side i
think that's cool
i like the way these look a lot i
believe in them someone put so much time
and energy into the design of these
headphones
mr odis i bet it was you
sennheiser he1 you know i use the
microphones and i've used a sennheiser
and i
think i like them so 50 grand
50 000
really are these the most expensive
headphones on the planet that's
unbelievable
that's truly unbelievable fifty thousand
dollars for a pair of headphones
i mean these are uh how can i not want
these
what could make them cost like
like in my mind like forty five hundred
forty five thousand more dollars than
what i imagine the most expensive
headphones
ever were you like two nice cars
i'm gonna read the details about this
one the amplifier sits on a housing
crafted from glass and a solid block of
carrera i mean
is that what i'm paying for natural
stone michelangelo each dial is milled
from a simple piece of brass little
vials next to it
1500 for a pair of headphones it's like
how can i even consider this
focal clear mg i mean come on i just saw
a 50 grand pair of headphones i'm not
interested in this
no no way 50 grand apple
no just 50 grand no oh these are
wireless
i bet these are sick honestly big fan of
apple
a big fan of wireless activity catch and
shoot
just getting shots up okay i'm gonna
pick the one that's
forty nine thousand dollars more than
the others
i'm gonna get the sennheisers
let's look at some warm blankets gucci
gg pattern throw blanket eleven hundred
dollars i'm not looking at it for like
sus i'm not looking at this for like
style i'm looking at this for substance
in terms of
warmth and the way it wraps it's like
great interior decorating but
i don't buy blankets as decorating
scully and scully heavy aroma cashmere
throw
fourteen hundred dollars roughly i like
the photograph
of it i don't know how that picture came
about but whoever is responsible for it
it's a great branding
first source custom full peltility for a
blanket is this real fur because you
know that's bad i don't like that that's
bad you're trying to get me wrapped up
in something
animals are great and no and i and no
thank you for even thinking that i would
like this
bloomingdale's pharaoh lindo blanket
just
not my texture it's very woolly or
something
air mass croquet is it hermes or hermes
hermes croquet
t gray blanket beautiful print i love
um tigers it's not a lion it's a tiger
it looks more like a place mat though
that's five grand
the elder statesman super soft striped
cashmere blanket again cashmere and it's
really a quirky pattern
i don't know kind of rubs me the wrong
way don't like it don't like it at all
for me it's scully and scully cashmere
throw
i mean look at the picture and i hope
everyone's seeing the picture that i'm
commenting on but it looks like like the
not even the king the prince of blankets
like a young
destined to be leader of the blankets
but like
it's still young and it's [ __ ] he
doesn't even have any of the
responsibilities of being the king it's
just like
next up and it's like fresh and warm and
good so i'm gonna go with that one
luggage luggage is important uh i'm
always on the go
and i am so into convenience and
um machines or not machines but it is a
machine or
you know just a way to uh optimize
utilitarian
i mean uh i don't know i don't know
about that i had to do some research on
that
it might be though
samsonite lightbox alu no
don't like this metal knock on it i need
something with soul something that looks
like it's from the midwest
crash baggage icon suitcase no no
it's just i mean somebody it's
somebody's dream luggage not mine
i get it though for it looks like it's
like what i envisioned like german
people would
travel with take it for what you will i
don't know i don't even know what i mean
by that
prada nylon and saffiano leather trolley
okay
look simple not flashy but a
designer somehow at the same time
understated
um i like it thirty three hundred
dollars the price i really
lack context with luggage i feel like i
buy it once every like four years
i'm very cheap and i feel like the
luggage i would buy would be like seven
hundred dollars or something like that's
cheap
yeah three thousand dollars a lot but
it's like it's not a sweatshirt
oh wait travel carry-on hate it not my
style don't like it stiff as a board
louis vuitton horizon 70 4100 um
you know overly branded for my liking
i'm not really a guy who likes uh
everything just like this is the brand
and it's like just splattered
so that's kind of how i feel
this table rolls
well i only liked one of them i really
actively disliked
every one but one and i like the one so
prada nylon and saffiano leather trolley
leather i look leather
well [ __ ] it prada
[Music]
cars automobiles again not a car guy i
don't get free cars at this point at
least i don't think i do
maybe i do get free cars i don't think i
do
i feel like like cuevo gets free cars or
something
2021 lamborghini aventador svj roadster
517 racks okay
you know all types of stats about it
770cv
566kw greater than 350 km
hour 2.9 s 0 to 100 km i mean i live in
america so kilometers i mean
um i feel like it's a slap in the face
this is this isn't a this is not
american made this car
okay so you know
we got enough to deal with in america
right now i guess it's nice i'm not
really like a fast like i'm not like a
fight
speed is like troubles me whatever a
throw seeker is i'm the opposite i'm
risk averse
i hate thrills don't seek them so
this is gonna be a pass it's also not my
interior type of vibe i need like
like a wood oak
2021 toyota avalon i mean if you're
getting a lamborghini or an avalon i
don't know i'd still pick the
lamborghini i guess but
it's cool nice interior hot leather up
until about two years ago
i had been driving a 2002 toyota avalon
for the past
decade great car my grandfather's car
gave it to my friend gaida
star of my show he pretty quickly got a
new car
i mean i think he got like a benz
honestly and it's pretty insulting for
all that i don't think i want to go back
down the toilet avalon route of my life
you know i've just there's been enough
chaos okay
2021 ford bronco wild track 46
980. i don't know i don't think i can
even drive a car this big without just
like constantly crashing it
you know i'm a horrible driver never
driven a car this big
would feel i mean i'm pretty sure it's
bad for the environment waiting for
a sustainable car to pop up gq so we'll
see how long this takes definitely not
getting this bronco
not it's really just not my taste at all
i don't think i need to say much else
about it and that's it there's no so
okay there's no good for the earth type
of stuff here
okay since it's not real i own a tesla
i will get the honestly i'll get the
i'll get the lamborghini i'll get the
lamborghini but not because i want to
it's a convertible and i've never you
know i've never had a convertible it
mess up my hair i think
you know it's loud but lamborghini i
guess
if i had to pick one item out of the
whole thing that i mean i would pick the
i mean the headphones not only are like
they
you know nothing do i use more than a
headphone but
i've i'm flabbergasted at the price at
fifty thousand for a pair of i can't
even believe it
i'm gonna make some calls right when i
leave here and see who i know that might
have that but i don't think anyone
has them quincy jones or somebody but
i don't know i if you said hey right now
i'll give you
the lamborghini or the headphones i
would 100 say the headphones
how much is the lamborghini i checked it
i would get the lamborghini i'd sell it
and then i buy the headphones